suite à l'attaque du centre LGBTI de
Touraine qui a eu lieu lundi un
rassemblement de soutien est en cours
depuis 18h30 à Tours place Anatole
France tout de suite on retrouve sur
place romain Delville romain il y a
beaucoup de personnes autour de vous
oui
on est en train de passer de 200
personnes à 300 personnes les gens
continuent justement de rejoindre le
rassemblement a initié par l'association
stop harcèlement de rue qui partage
justement les locaux du centre LGBTI de
Tours rue de rue des Tanneurs et donc
vous le voyez un dernier mois différents
drapeaux de bien sûr de de mouvement
politique on aperçu le NPA il y a
également le syndicat SUD solidaire qui
est présent avec les étudiants les
jeunes communistes nous avons également
aperçu l'écharpe du maire de thon
accompagné de Philippe Geiger et de
Christophe Dupin adjoint la sécurité et
à la culture en effet c'est un donc un
rassemblement je vous le disais qui
grossit deux minutes en minutes qui a
commencé il y a les une quinzaine de
minutes puisque un peu en réaction
justement au fait qu'un individu vous le
disait avant d'Alizée a lancé une
bouteille remplie d'acide et d'aluminium
lundi dans l'après-midi à l'intérieur du
centre lgbi de Touraine change tu aurais
pu causer une grosse explosion depuis le
parquet a ouvert une enquête pour
tentative d'assassinat on peut le dire
vous le dit vous le rappeliez c'est la
6e attaque du centrage GBI LGBTI de
Touraine mais là on peut dire que c'est
monté d'un cran Nadia Ségué secrétaire
général de la préfecture revient sur les
mesures mises en place elle répond au
micro de Clémence dosc
le préfet a provoqué hier une réunion
avec les représentants de l'association
la Direction Départementale emploi à
travail et solidarité pour examiner la
mise en oeuvre immédiate des mesures qui
peuvent l'être il a également insisté
pour que l'ensemble des activités de
cette association et donc la préparation
de la prochaine Marche des fiertés du 17
juin face l'objet d'un dispositif
particulièrement soigné attentif pour
que cette manifestation se déroule dans
les meilleures conditions possibles le
renforcement des patrouilles de police
est effectif avec la police municipale
également donc c'est ce sont des mesures
qui sont en place et qui perdureront
justement la évoqué on entend la rumeur
qui qui grandit derrière moi preuve que
l’influence elle-même grandit sur sur la
place Anatole France c'est vrai que les
marques de soutien se sont répétés au
cours au cours de la semaine à
différents échelons justement et que
soit locaux départementaux ou régionaux
et c'est important justement de pouvoir
montrer Nadia vous le rappeler que cette
cette atmosphère aujourd'hui qui n'est
pas celle d'un recueillement qui n'est
pas forcément un moment grave mais en
tout cas à un moment de solidarité et
qui doit justement prouver le 17 juin
par la Marche des fiertés qui débutera
au château de Tours dans l'après-midi
que le peuple que la population est avec
les gens qui sont LGBTI de Tours